here's what would happen if we dumped
100 million tons of trash into a volcano
lava Lakes are incredibly unstable so if
you throw something cold into lava it
would trigger a chain reaction of
pressurized and acidic steam so what
happens when you throw 100 million tons
of garbage into it well for any old
phone cases in this pile of garbage
they'd begin to melt creating a
poisonous gas that would spread let's
take all those old phone cases and
instead give them to case defy they have
the world's largest recycling program
you give them your old phone case and
they'll make a completely new one so
let's take out the old phone cases and
see what happens next a massive
explosion would occur one that climbs
hundreds of meters up into the air and
the pollution hook the pollution without
a filter dropping this much trash into a
hot lava lake would spread poisonous
fumes for hundreds of meters this
doesn't look good